ya sea Arizona Texas O Madrid el calor
se hizo sentir en el mundo el martes por
segundo día consecutivo la temperatura
media global alcanzó los 17,18 grados
Celsius el día más caluroso registrado
en al menos 44 años ya el lunes se había
fijado un récord pero apenas se mantuvo
por 24 horas today
hace dos días el mundo vivió la
temperatura más alta jamás registrada
Celsius de media Global en global auge
los expertos estiman que este mismo
miércoles se podría convertir en el
tercer día consecutivo en el que la
tierra marca un récord de altas
temperaturas Pero esto no es una
sorpresa para algunos científicos que
aseguran que el cambio climático seguirá
llevando las temperaturas hacia arriba
tenemos previsto que el mundo se
caliente Y por consiguiente que se sigan
rompiendo récords Pero el hecho de que
esos récords se rompieran en magnitudes
nunca antes vistas es de por sí bastante
preocupante
estas temperaturas más altas han
generado olas de calor en países como
India dejando docenas de Muertos china
registró su mes de junio más caluroso en
60 años los científicos afirman que es
probable que eventos de clima extremo
como estos sean más frecuentes urgen a
los gobiernos a Que se preparen para los
peores escenarios